donc il ya le raid normalement qui part
up j et là on va de nouveau avoir une
petit espace panau
abbaoui
j'essaie de comprendre pourquoi j'ai pas
l'échiquier ici
et voilà la petite espagnole qui par
nature baudron du coup aujourd'hui je
sais pas je peux vous ferez pas en quel
état d'esprit une épaule est ce que il
veut se refaire une santé physique
dormir entre faire la sieste il est
chaud il prend des risques
l'ex gossip est un
après vous qu'ils nous fassent plus
d'une demi-heure
pour comme la pub pourquoi il a pu la
poule basse
cette personne avait oublié de jouer b5
sait pas
on va voir et ce qui rentre dans le
marshall cette foire si ce qu'il a l'air
fatigué déjà n'est pas
bon signe on alors tenir
il doit vraiment épuisé après la partie
d'hier mais je pense que m'a glissé une
meilleure condition physique
ça doit être dur pour les peaux après si
tu fais nul là c'est qu'il va reprendre
la foudre demain
à la foudre dont la petite pluie fine en
fait pendant huit heures avec un peu de
vent texte bien ta tronche et refaite en
but ainsi l'arrêt visait en fait de cela
il a dû tout révisé vrai
c'est contre ces quatre jours ouais si
l'aura pas à nouveau 1 6 4 aujourd'hui
on va voir ce que ça c'est intéressant
ce combat-là début de partie
entre les deux âmes fab
on se répète dès 6 7 3 b 4 télé cool
jour
[Musique]
il lui reste quatre parties avec les
blancs n'est pas
si gâche celle-là il en restera plus 3
c'est pas énorme
d'être
il avait commencé par ces trois
dernières fois
ça change un peu
ça change un petit peu vrai un petit
clic différents quoi
ok détroit en fait il veut peut-être des
3 c3 et 10,4 ouais bon moi prendre de
temps tu changes porte deux coups
mais bon je je continue à penser que
c'est pas un bon choix mais
de s'enfoncer dans ce truc là elle fab
parce que il a prouvé qu'il jouait moins
bien
dans ses positions là et il va en jouer
sept dans le match
il est un peu tête une épaule
de perdre sur une variante insipide
choisi une variante encore plus longue
de l'espagnol ouais c'est ça
mais bon après avec les blancs il va pas
perdre mais juste y semble semble quand
même moins fort que ma guise dont gens
négligent genre de situation et
mais bon après peut-être qu'ils pensent
qu'ils trouvent quelque chose avec les
blancs dans ses variantes 1 et qui
veulent essayer de
te prendre l'aventage à toutes les
parties ça peut aussi s'entendre mais
bon il en reste plus tant que ça
et avec les noirs on voit que
né peut se retrouvent
dans des positions qui gère mal
ton petit filière ab je pense qu'il
s'est trompé de filière avant le match
en fait
après avons tous le droit de changer
d'avis en croûte de tête qui n'ont pas
hésité dans les ouvertures autres
regardez trop de choses ils ont trop de
retard les reins a été faite peut-être
dans le choix de bon dans des seconds en
notamment car yakine vrai que prendre un
looser dans ton équipe c'est bien si tu
veux perdre et peut-être qu'il aurait
fallu s'entourer
winner
et tu vois un certain cramique peut-être
tu aurais pu le conseil après commises
et blattes peut-être que cramique lui
n'a pas forcément envie que n'est pas
gagne à bon
ouais voilà simple et bonne raison que
le tank ya pas d'autres us qui gagne le
dernier en attrait
japon par enterrer quoi ils jouent plus
quoi ça va
à j-6
placé comme design je regarde fièrement
un sens
36 et jouer son genre position et du
coup tu vas apprendre après chaque
défaite
encore une confiance doivent a pris
comme quichotte j'ai beaucoup appris
dans ce match oui bon
la prochaine fois tu vas pas prendre à
perdre de jarnac
et poli il est quand même très souvent
debout on en a beaucoup parlé mais bon
enfin un moment donné
pour gagner une partie faut aussi être à
6 1
c'est pas vrai combat homérique la
rose et le temps
les autres champions les joueurs quitter
aussi souvent la table dans caruana
carlson non mais parce que caruana
s'élève pas tant que ça
ça fait beaucoup
même si les joueurs globalement c'est
vraiment beaucoup on va dire que dans ce
championnat du monde spécifiquement
comme dépôt est déjà parmi ceux qui se
lèvent le plus basse et plus voyants
vous à tutu peut zapper les images aller
voir d'autres partis
fais-moi
politique de la chaise vide quoi
bein russie reste pas est un action qui
est quand même plus fusent et à
cyberpresse et je pensais juste que
l'epo il est trop stressé un ce dont on
a parlé assez souvent déjà mais ça s'est
vu dans les couilles rcd faute de stress
en fait ils n'arrivent pas à se détendre
et du coup ça fait ça me fait penser à
certaines finales de roland garros
notamment ostapenko alep où il y avait
un myskina dementieva un petit peu comme
ça
s'applique à mal
je regarde jamais des finales de roland
garros femmes
ça ressemble un peu à ça ou tu as
souvent une joueuse qui se reportent qui
se libère pas ouais ouais ouais ça
arrive assez souvent dans dans le tennis
féminin ça arrive assez souvent et c'est
vrai que ça ressemble un petit peu à
saturer hier en fait on a fait des
mauvaises comparaison en vrai on n'y a
pas pensé mais c'est vrai que ça
ressemble un peu à ça
un peu de craquage psychologique plus
que n'est peut-être que jusque dans du
joko nadal federer
wawrinka l'erdre ça fait plaisir qu'en
fait c'est te libères
n'ont rien à perdre et deuxième truc
c'est que on a aussi souvent le cas
quand c'est des mecs qui jouent les
grands chelems mais que c'est la
première finale majeure du temps
bon là ok tu passes il a fait son match
et fabrice était pas à sa première
finale mondiale il y joue
série jouve à l'hyper pentue et
tu as plein de joueurs qui arrivent pas
à part finale
victoire des verts face aux bretons pas
forcé pas en fait tout autre je suis pas
spécialement confiant ni bons hans à
jour enfin oui mais bon là c'est un
format fabu tu m'aimes pendant pendant
deux semaines fin tu peux te calmer quoi
la première partie je veux bien mais là
c'est déjà ça c'était hier c'était sa
sixième partie pour sa sixième finale
bon
je sais pas connaît en fait déjà en fait
ça ressemble un peu à ça tu vois je
réfléchissais cette nuit et je me disais
ça ressemble un peu plus au tennis
féminin en fait dont le dans le stress
août un peu ça aussi un souvent des
finales
sa turbo
turbo streller wind quoi ouais turbo
twin turbo loose quoi ta du turbo
bat soderling
je sais pas je pense qu'il a fait si mal
aux finales contre rogers c'était juste
le stick
shooter vrai avec moi j'ai enfin fait
d'arrêter quand même bien favori un
lacet l'a77
après il regrette c'est
ok c'est 3 hockey et encore trois
parties dans la base mais
pas trop de joueurs de l'élite le plus
fort à avoir joué ces naissances ou aux
bons petits mecs ou
en fait je suis tellement d'accord avec
vlad je vois pas dans quel monde n'est
pas où te plaît magnus dans ses
positions la
mise à part gars vraiment mais bon hein
mais l'autre jour sa fille mais juste
vous faire ses gammes enfin un moment
faut vraiment faire le bon coup quand à
l'occasion un prix globalement je pense
n'est pas à mieux jouer mise à part les
moments de stress je pensais le premier
match au championnat du monde où karte
scène pour moi sur l'échiquier devine
pas vraiment mais dans la tête il est
tellement faible n'est pas
ce que sur le sur le jeu sur les clics
il était il est légèrement au dessus en
fait étape à mende jeu pendant un bon
moment c'est comme si intrinsèquement en
fait il était devenu aussi fort que
magnus voire même un peu plus fort mais
en fait c'est un jeu où tu peux pas
faire deux autant de gaffe
car il reste juste prix d'ouverture
quand la mesa 2,04 c'était bien s'il a
dominé dans le milieu du jeu en fait
c'est retrouver mieux mais après c'est
ce qu'ils disent en conf de presse ce
qu'ils voulaient jeu pour gagner ça
c'est bien sauf qu'en fait c'est le fait
pousser à prendre de mauvaises décisions
et en plus le pire c'est que j'ai vu
après la conférence de presse en russie
l'avait leroy g6 il dit oui bon je
faisais pas d'âme le catch 3g 6 nuls
facile mais pourquoi dame bertrade à 24
en fait c'est hallucinant fait
mérogis tours 9
c'est tellement bizarre
il a vraiment donné la partie sans
raison ouais c'est ça
incroyable en fait surtout qu'il a donné
plusieurs fois en magnus il n'a pas
saisi la première opportunité qui était
dur avec 50 secondes dans la peau d'un
bon il a quand même laissé coi
et ouais non c'était donc vrai en fait
intrinsèquement dans le jeu n'est pas il
a l'air un peu plus fort juste j'ai
l'impression qui craque un peu et que et
que
et qui a pas mis en place les prépas
avec les blancs parce qu'au final les
deux fois où il a été bien c'est avec
les noirs
mais avec les blancs
vont dire il oscille l'a pas fait donc
il était pas bien il a raté les
occasions alors qu'avec les noirs deux
fois il a juste été mieux
agir c'est quand même rare en
championnat du monde d'avoir les
positions au blanc et au noir
est juste un truc qui se passait
alors après est ce que cette défaite
d'hier au contraire le libérer et se
dire comme des fois en tennis féminin
c'est pour ça qu'un état fort et pas si
nul que ça en plus c'est qu'il ya des
matchs du foyer sont les genres 6 1 3 2
3 3 2 tout fabriqué et tout d'un coup on
retourne à l'as tu te détente a presque
perdu et ça enchaîne
ce qui peut se passer quelque chose
comme ça peut-être un
magnus était pas censé rejouer les
blancs aujourd'hui alors que moi j'avais
eu l'information un petit moment sur le
site officiel que sa double et les
blancs à ce moment du match ouais mais
non mais en fait c'est parce qu'ils
s'étaient trompés et du coup ça a été
changé entre temps ou qu'ils ont changé
d'avis
non mais
on prend ce qu'ils faisaient en fait ils
te faisais une première moitié de match
raté deux matchs et il y avait un qui
conseille que les blancs et pour la
deuxième moitié de match on change
l'ordre c'est l'autre qui consacre les
blancs donc ça marche quand c'est un
nombre quand la moitié ses pairs quoi
lanta 12 parties ou 16 et cécile sous
vide et là on va être arrêté bizarre
parce que là on arrive à mi match donc
en fait chamboulerait tout quoi
aussi les jours de repos cette fois ci
ils ont changé voilà la petite c2 2 2 et
la c3 2 3 à 2 c pour vraiment pas savoir
quand ça joue à
fait
je trouve ça logique en fait on va
arriver à mi match ce soir et pourra
commencer les matches aller on va dire
avec les blancs et pour la deuxième
partie du match tellement réduites ces
400 cas les blancs en fait finalement
pays sans avoir à faire doubler
personnes ils font ce qu'ils veulent
faire donc n'ai pas de raison de doubler
quoi
rhmani c'est un trou non justice juin au
faciès et microsoft réveillé
en me cherche un peu bon j'me des pièces
à quoi ça ressemble et ses textes 1
et peut prendre ces tours 8 par le coup
de plus logique
je sais pas
on a vite tout est possible
3 8
entouré de lecouls qui me viendrait
après si ça se trouve tu aimes des
17,2 me suis tout aussi je ne sais pas
ce que tu peux faire alors un peu claqué
un magnus
il est pas bien
là je crois qu'ils sont crevés là je
crois qu'ils sont les 2ème et c'est
vraiment fatiguant ce qu'ils ont fait
hier mais là ça se voit qu'il est quand
même pas au mieux non
bon la posture et dépôts mieux après bon
c'est qu'il fait plein de sports il est
donc forme en général donc on sait que
soit crevé après dix minutes de jeu
c'est marrant en fait aux échecs il ya
deux manières de te faire mal jouer et
d'être peu de temps beaucoup te faire
jouer à fond pour t'épuises et que tu
joues mal quand même
c'est beaucoup quoi
by ap al her and on l'appela refrain
groves et images mais bon
première réussie vers claqué quoi en le
pot il n'a pas l'air bien
fun glace pour récupérer
n'empêche si on rigole on rigole mais ce
truc de blandas peut-être que sa tête de
ou feint même osé chacun la crypto
comment s'appelle agrio cryothérapie
septembre et au terrassement ouais c'est
djoko il fait par exemple
mais même dans les vestiaires tas de
fois dans les sports co dans le bain
les glaçons au pit y vas tu te gêne un
peu sept
premiers trous vigueur qu atre aucun cas
et aux thérapies
encore 8 en or à la première pause du
coup on a décidé de faire comme ça
25000 de 4 5 minutes de pub et on se
barre et on revient et on revient à vue
que sartre aucune grande frustration de
peut-être raté 32 commentaires pendant
une pub si on parle toujours on va
partir pour la pub ça vous me manquerez
absolument rien ce sera mieux
c'est ce qu'on nous a dit et tout à
l'avenant le chat en fait
ce que vous avez tout à l'heure dans le
chalet ça il n'y a pas tellement de gens
qui l'ont reproché sa depuis depuis
depuis six jours on voit des trucs
machins tout au moins on aura très rien
les gens qui seraient bons choix
on sait que c'est un bon choix
mais oui la cryothérapie ça peut être
utile je pense à des temps plus
mais moi j'avais bien sûr c'est un sauna
après un petit seau d'eau froide
cette main ferme quoi
bon en magnus
qui connaît pas qui doit compter sur sur
le fait qu'il est plus fort que son
adversaire dans ses positions en réalité
jusque sur sa prépa
déjà dû revoir à des tonnes un soir de
position toute façon ils jouent ça
depuis des dizaines d'années
je revis après un coup que les ordis
propose plus ou moins c'est peut être
cavaliers b4 on sait pas qu'on tue qu'on
trouve un peu bien des 5 tu n'y a pas de
piora donc ya pas deux à trois et tu
peux libérer le plan c'est
donc pourquoi pas en fait c'est assez
logique et b4 souvent on voit sauter à 5
dans les espagnols mais se fait t 4
alarcon des cadres a priori même logique
après une seule réponse qui semble
convaincante d'après les ordi mais ça
reste à voir si ces 5 t pas le coup
[Musique]
reprise qui prend le saint qui veut
faire ses quatre étoiles font à deux
est juste un petit dames 6
je voulais qu'on pense
intéressant la d4 c'est clair c'est un
sérieux test à cali et b4
et b4 peut-être faire d'autre jarque
avait lieu deux
des cinq de large et 3 comme d'hab je te
fais ces trois ont été rasées 5 est
clairement des noirs ces trois cas ici
6,1 kg 3
voilà plus ou moins normal quoi comme
position et des cats qui arrive après
je ne sais pas
ça peut être mais qui avait cadré c'est
une option après moi je te dis j'aurais
jamais favorisé un cahier g3 ouais c'est
claudine et 85 2 caps blancs et 97 au
noir alors que les blancs sont mieux
c'est pour dire à quel point ce truc de
cap c'est n'importe quoi tu as beaucoup
moins bien joué mais tu as gagné bravo
comme celle quoi
tuer beaucoup plus fort là tu dois pas
gagné à toi de jouer ah bon qui était le
coût qui ne serait plus logique de bazin
met
donc pour faire fuiter faut aussi ce
quoi
et donc il a bien fait le h6 comme
l'autre fois dans sa lettre à toutes les
g5 et aussitôt avec fougue et 5 une fois
qu'il faut partir
au cannet pauvres
mais il va rien obtenir la fin je suis
tellement sûr qu'ils en incapacité de
battre magnus dans ce truc là
bon des fois en fait il ya un truc qui
peut se passer dans ses positions dans
un nid avantage c'est que
gérard tu fais je suis pas fou d'edouard
fritch tu foulquier en d5 il te bouffe
tu prends du pillon viande et 4 du
bouffon du client et à la colonna est à
fois 5
pas beaucoup mais c'est un petit truc où
tu vas jouer longtemps est allé droit tu
vas mettre un peu ta dam en f3 peut-être
un peu plus facile d'attaquer des quatre
genre de choses alors là bon j'imagine
tout cas et des cats étaient imprécis un
point noir dans lequel deux sets
sur
mais bon peut-être faire du secure être
jetez pas sur ta vos goûts pas je sais
quoi tu repars quoi trouver votre
observation et n'avait pas sûr
ça peut être ce genre de position qui
paraît mais si tu arrives à ce truc un
peu symétrique ou quoi tu peux essayer
de travailler quand même et que les
blancs
oui
mais bon le truc ce combat le biais de
penser que toute façon c'est
l'impression qui plaît à magnus qui joue
pas mal même pas un bien c'est le cas
non way et que né paul joue moins et que
du coup on n'est pas inquiet alors qu'on
fait en soit la position elle joue au
moins largement tout autant qu'hier
c'est quoi c'est mieux ou moins bien que
ses quattro s'est moins bien revient
c'est vrai était moins sûre c'est
peut-être mieux mais mettez moins
confiants on monte une joue quoi
bon
des cinq tout de suite bien sûr mais je
pense que nous devons pas prendre cette
fois-ci juste faire x fi de
bouffer après une faute sur la caisse de
s'être libéré pour le cavalier
revient pas à nespouls en tout cas
pour trop vite en tout cas c'est le coup
le plus précis le plus logique donc tout
ça pour dire que j'arrive à fait de la
merde derrière
non non c'est une caméra un huitième
round ouais
mais
[Musique]
non mais t'as vu l'arbitré attachons
aussi un vrai
oued entourent vite voilà c'est que
c'est le coup le plus logique de la
position donc en fait signer peau et
dans sa prépa et il semblerait qu un
rôle aussi vite normalement il s'était
même pose qui joue et il n'y a pas trop
hésité quoi lac du temps comme dame
calmes qu'on avait un ouais moi tu
tournes
ne te montre plus trop l'audience en
fait non tu as vu public doit pas
publier lui battu et qui avait personne
quoi donc du coup c'est un peu embêtant
ce que je propose en fait c'est que il
est il et 55 on a pu mais cinq minutes
de pause ne vous met pas la musique
chasse comme que je trouve un peu aux
rives on vous laisse la caméra la grande
calmes
et on se retrouve dans sam je propose
qu'on fasse comme ça parce que la
musique je la trouve un peu
agressive ouais
ok je pense que vous en pensez on fait
comme ça
allez sa part
voit la pub et on se retrouvera dans
cinq minutes a tout de suite a tout de
suite les gars
alors dieu non retour
donc à part on s'était quittés grand
chose mais accueille des cinq qui
arrivait donc voilà le coup joué par par
dépôt et bah du coup on vous avait dit
on s'attend à bafouer fuite dessus qui
paraît logique parce que les marrons pas
hyper a envie de prendre maintenant
jusqu'à près puis on prend ce cavalier
est attaqué
et il a pas ça casse dans le set donc
soyez bien là et on va pouvoir jouer la
structure symétrique donc c'est pas
grand chose mais c'est quand même une
colonne pour les blancs et ce fou qui
peut s'activer de ce côté et faire
pression là bas donc petit à petit les
blancs au pouvoir amener les tours sur
la colonne a et c est avoir une légère
pression donc c'est plutôt sympathique
pour les blancs sage je rende pas trop
noir je pense mais donc faire fuite bon
ben ok cache le fou
maintenant aux blancs de jouer donc et
skype a reçus rendu fou des deux fous
ici et on laisse prendre qui comprend et
il ya cavaliers 7 ou alors est-ce qu'il
veut remettre son cavalier en deux trois
pourquoi pas ference on sait que c'est
une bonne case ici parce qu'on peut
venir à 25 un jour parce qu'on empêche
des 5 on peut y venir sur un moment et
peut-être faire ces trois des quatre à
préparer petit à petit mon pas si simple
exception mais pourquoi pas
préparé peut-être des quatre sites où
courent ça peut être c'est peut être une
idée même si
perso après faut aussi je me dis toi par
trop de
trop de danger pour les marques donc sur
fouet fuite bon c'est pas mal en
streaming mise à jouer je sais pas s'il
va faire ça s'il va développer le fou ou
bon notre idée bien sûr ses terres ses
trois assez rarement mauvais
peut-être me prendre à ce moment là
soit puis on prend et des quatre fous
prendront la partie et on repart en
laisse pas de fou quand même est
ok peut-être qu'ils g6 grain
aux trois faut aussi un truc comme ça
bon après il peut essayer d'avoir ce
genre de truc je sais pas si on fait
d'un b3 surmonte le tour à 6 à 7 si on
fait des quatre
ça peut essayer je veux dire c est puisé
espoir pour les blancs même si bon
scénar tout semble plus ou moins correct
mais bon il semblerait qu'il ait fait
faux et fuites magnus
je pouvais voir à la cam ici il a joué
frais fuite ok
donc c'est bien la pression d'un studio
et ses années peau donc de choisir
donc je vous dis soit c3 qui semble pas
qu'on soit on développe le fou sauf
peut-être quelques années mais j'aime
moi je vais l'enlever des options
d'ailleurs
bon je sais pas à ces trois limites
c'est ce qui me plaît le plus sur ce
qu'on a regardé voilà donc donc on va
voir
on va voir
un retour de kiev avec les petits
matches à merci beaucoup
je te dire femme que vlad est très
heureux
la position
il a toujours su relancer complètement
suffit de faire pardonner pour jouer ça
une nouvelle fois et comme il le disait
dans nos scrabble à ducey avant-hier en
fait
ouais ça tours 8 h 6 soit fuite une fois
qu'on vincent une fois dans l'autre mais
moi j'avais pour forte après pas
exact ouaip 8 façon c'est toujours pas
de faim tu rentres dans les positions de
carlson donc que c'est ça ira pas quoi
tout commence au final finir ouais
magnus qui doit vraiment être très
content du déroulement du match pour le
moment
parce que c'est vrai qu'il est pas du
tout en danger au final
ce com comme tu disais le ckd c'est vrai
qu'il a été raté par un dépôt mais
en fait je pense que tu commences à être
en danger après que le coup c'est 400 à
arriver sur l'échiquier tant que tu l'as
pas jouer tu met pas en danger le bras
puis c4 c'est pas pour autant qu'ils
aient gagné mais jure-t-il avait un truc
sympathique loi
[Musique]
donc ouais on va voir
on va voir comment ça
évolue aujourd'hui mais
james hook n'est poussé vraiment enfermé
dans un truc
dans la seule partie qui est dans cette
position c'est une simultanée de
nouvelles comme télécom sudparis
maintenant pic pour sa ville serait il
avait joué ses trois des coûts que
sont la logique dans la position
fou et 3g tout foot et d'eau peut-être
voilà c'est ça tu peux sortir le fou
mais bon à ce moment là il va te bouffer
et caillau 7
bat d'ailleurs il pourrait même de faire
fossile mais bon ça c'est la plus
logique
et à la fin ça c'est quand même un
facteur de la position qui
un peu mieux
on va voir quand ça joue s'il va
vraiment rien à voir si manning a
égalisé comme il le fait depuis le début
du match mais aussi pour une fois il va
jouer le coup fin au bon moment
peut-être créer un petit truc
quand même pas mal de réfléchir en fait
côté n'est pas
un petit conseil quand même
être devant l'échiquier ça peut aider à
trouver des coûts peut-être un moment
donné
tu vas y arriver il a manqué de temps
finalement
il peut peut-être s'en vouloir d'avoir
autant gaspiller de temps
sortez vos chaussures prénom avait
toujours un coup la réponse est juste
forcé ouais mais tu repères du temps
alors général est finalement peut-être
que les dix minutes qui lui a manqué
il les a perdus dans ces allers retours
incessants aux toilettes
est fou qui n avait qu une bouteille en
fait un bidon puis hop rien on les voit
rien dans les poches
non mais c'est pas si anodin en fait un
les gens pensent contrôler tout meyer
vraiment il aurait eu 10 minutes de plus
la partie la paire des parrains cette
même ville gagna tête même qui gagne est
vrai ça se joue sur des détails le haut
niveau
et mais malheureusement j'ai
l'impression qu'
il peut pas il peut pas faire cet effort
en fait de de jouer jouer une partie
d'échecs je vais aussi wacey ouais
ouais mais s'ils avaient eu dix minutes
de plus car ça n'aurait fait en fonction
aussi énormément fin
nous savons si tu es fou crambés 4 tu
peux faire en fonction si tu veux mais
tu es moins bien oui mais ne t'inquiète
pas et carlson aurait quand même fait en
fonction
bah non feinte bail il aurait fait ce
qu'il a pu ce jour là mais il a été
justement bien
si tu sers à 280 km ta première balle je
ferai quand même en retour gagnant
facilement d'air ne t'inquiète pas
j'allais ça pour un coût j'avais la
gastro je suis venu avec un seau pour
vomir dedans pendant l'épreuve ouais
mais ça c'est c'est beau joueur ces
bourgeois way
peut-être qu'ils affichent aussi bien
devant un son écran dans son box enfin
des fois tu as un coup évident tu sais
ce que tu vas jouer tu pars tu reviens
tu perds une minute quand même un bouton
de marche toute façon
non mais là je ne sais pas où il est
c'est génitaux
q1 mais c'est étonnant verte a perdu
hier t'as pas envie d'un peu de montrer
un autre visage je suis maître le
discours de laurent sciarra quoi
c'est un gentil garçon né peau
alors que carl salue la latitude
la bonne attitude l'attitude attitude
correcte l'attitude qu'il faut
l'attitude du champion
ces années peau de jouer ils continuent
à calculer réfléchir regarde la position
ils calculent c'est exactement ce qu'il
faut faire et c'est ce que magnus fait
ça m'étonnerait pas de voir manu se
doubler la marque aujourd'hui fab a
carrément carrément
carrément fab mais bon on va voir si
c'est magnus peut tuer le match
aujourd'hui si double la marque ici le
match est plié bah disons là il a dès
aujourd'hui et demain où il a encore les
blancs il va tenter clermont après bon
il rejoint de repos ça repart un peu sur
un autre petit cycle est là clairement
magnus il ya des sortes de balles de
match il a envie aujourd'hui il s'est
hissé qui pelote c'est simple comme tu
es dans les choix de fumer à tête dedans
résidente et xian tu veux faire la
chasse un pet
valu c1 c'est un requin à quoi
clairement regarde
s'il sent qu'il peut te déboîté va faire
et là il sans ironie fle sans refuge où
est né pauvre
tu sais ce que tu vas jouer j'imagine si
tu reviens
non mais en fait il me plains et
risquent de perdre 20 c'est tout ja
c'est normal en fait de perdre quand tu
fais ça
tu peux pas être champion du monde en
salle en fait
tu peux plus v mille fois pendant une
partie tu peux te le fais une fois
pendant 1000 parties mais tu peux pas te
lever mille fois pendant 1000 parties
qu'au bout d'un moment
ce possible ce n'est plus possible
tu peux pas en fait
showcase à lui de gérer comme il le sent
agir comme ils le savaient qu'il aura
perdu le match il géra comme il le sent
alors qu'on est là c'est bien aussi
chacun gère tout comme il veut mais je
m'emballe est qu'un face c'est pas moi
qui suis en train de perdre une finale à
rome c'est dommage fin c'est dommage ce
qui n'était pas loin hier en fait il là
il là il à karl scène il l'a en fait il
est pas moins fort il perd sur des
détails il perd sur des détails
la rave qui marche sur la cité de la
peur mais qui ne marche pas ici c'est
pas la cité de la peur ça avoir mis une
colle gremm
ouvre un livre d'histoire féraud ça te
détendra non mais le mec essaye de te
reprendre il connaît pas les situations
dangereuses nicole thomas déjà parce
qu'on sait aussi c'est de la peur mais
les fans
il se trouve que c'est aussi bob marley
en fait un mais il se trouve que savoir
lincoln
ça à l'organisation de demander plus de
présence faut pas déconner mais c'est
pas faim et lui fait ce qu'ils venaient
enfin s'il veut perdre le match il a le
droit
de la station blinken ça vous intéresse
on peut tromper une partie du peuple
tout le temps et tout le peuple une
partie du temps on ne peut pas tromper
tout le peuple tout le temps abraham
lincoln
et ben oui qu'est ce qu'il a dit je te
dirai après le live de qui parlez
bah oui bah oui bah oui et à propos
cédant 1 10
donc
ouais by jove stand up ouais ouais
comme des trous du cul dans ses lives
abraham aide lincoln and
père fondateur ou pas
c'est quoi premier président non
regarde
ah non on n'est pas du tout 16e prix
georges moitié georges le premier
george washington ouais
né en 1809
bombes assassiner d'ailleurs en 1865
l'arrière intéressante
table
sa chanson qu'il a r qui est un peu de
colonna mais non c'est pas grand chose
le fou qui va advenir en six mois de
taux et tu vas te faire ivan
alors moi en tant que client des 5 tu
veux je peux pas trop faire ça
car il y va bien devoir sauter en
bas ou se faire bouffer
[Musique]
c'est censé être sa paie pas sa position
il par 20 minutes et ne sais pas quoi
joue en revenant
ce mic arts et culture de la défaite
c'est magnifique quoi c'est pas un
pétard poté pas
dense étonnant
parce que là vraiment magnus ce que
jouer des trucs normaux
au piège du commentaire sportif c'est de
chercher des raisons exhaustive un
résultat de façon rétrospective pour ça
qu'ils ont tout et n'importe quoi donc
on leur serre sur le temps long alors le
seul problème c'est qu'en fait ce qu'on
a dit à propos de nepos a été cité avant
le match on fait donc là c'est quand
même le problème logis ça c'est le
problème des gens dans le chat qui
n'écoutent pas un contenu et qui juge ce
que les gens disent c'est un autre
problème en fait
c'est un peu comme à discuter d'un livre
de quelqu'un mais tu l'as pas lui ça
arrive un mérite celui que des extraits
oui et tu prends des trucs hors de leur
contexte où on prend une phrase on mieux
d'un truc et là il se trouve que le fait
qu'il fallait pas aller dans l'espagnol
et qu'il fallait pas s'enfoncer dans
cette filière du match et que ce serait
le piège dans lequel il faut pas tomber
pour les pauvres les pièces
non mais bon alors que l'épreuve et
s'est dit avant
pourquoi dame prend des points même si
je comptais pas trop hein
un coup pour pour les noirs ce qui va
trouver j'ai trouvé fab une chance sur
deux d'être ya trouvé et très vite d'air
bail avec un seul coup
mais tu joues pour ces trois des quatre
maintenant ça a pas l'air grand-chose
infâme
il va essayer ces trois des quatre mais
bon
je vais développer le fou je sais pas
mais made me soucier pape sy juste pour
faire nul vite
c'est possible ouais c'est pas une
mauvaise stratégie en réalité faire nous
vite
c'est bon c'est trop
il est dès qu'il espérait pions prend à
la vie royale fit aussi qu'ils perdaient
sur quel point on dépense de jeunes
ne tombe dans aucun piège
et non demain ça joue un jeu la question
passé ces deux sèvres m3 2,3
à
qui n'aura pas lieu
on peut ne pas avoir lieu
je sais pas
mettre une petite pression pas étonné
mais qui sait
il est pas bien les ponts et ses
recharges du regard mais
il faut ici c'est toujours à lui je suis
très heureux d'avoir vu une autre façon
de faire nul dans l'anti marque j'ai
beaucoup appris aujourd'hui
sa nature baudron dans le tchad pas sûr
je sais pas encore non mais pas de la
position séparé des kills qui joue n'est
pas du tout un objectif lancer des coups
très correct c'est juste que carl scène
il est très à l'aise hors de position on
a du mal à imaginer
né peut jouer mieux carlson ici et elle
va du crédit difficulté c'était le
diagnostic avant le match bon vu les
premières parties où il a vu les blancs
on a un nom de 3,25
juste ça confirme ce qu'on pensait avant
oui en fait suivi la même position pour
un joueur genre un peu en dessous ou
bien peut-être qu'on dingoo je sais pas
qui en fait 27 et 25 ans j'en parle
navarra au hasard
tu dis que mes poèmes mais en fait tu
vas mettre pression c'est juste le
facteur carlson ici qui est évident
c'est pas évident ses positions la
quarantaine c'est probablement le
meilleur joueur de l'histoire du jeu
d'échecs en fait il est juste incroyable
dans ses positions et a du mal à
l'imaginer
suez font ici
surtout qu'en plus la carte c'est
normalement il a essayé il est chaud et
il va vraiment bien joué
une chape de plomb qui est tombé en
gagnant enfin une partie 5e quatre ans
que cinq ans qui avait pas gagné une
partie on se souvient du monde donc bon
on va le soulager et puis il a pris le
lead donc bon ça va quoi il concèdera
peu plus tranquille
juste le facteur que en général plus le
match avance plus on monte en puissance
inhérents
c'est juste en championnat du monde en
tournant un peu partout c'est souvent
comme ça
ouais
je fais n'est pas ce que j'ai
l'impression que dans les positions
compliqué il n'a rien à envier à magnus
genre vraiment eu après re catalan
compliqué oui hier où on sait plus
d'erreurs de stress mais dans le jeu il
était bien en fait
c'est dommage de son bourg b là dedans
avec les blancs quand même
vous venez encore combien d'années car
la scène off ça peut encore durer un
petit moment
ça va aussi dépendre de lui mais pour
l'instant ils lâchent pas la faire donc
voilà en tout cas il reste assis c'est
bien allez allez peut-être besoin de
souffler au début et c'est important
qu'ils fassent l'effort
c'est un entraîneur comme ça il faut
travailler sur l'échiquier
je fais pas le boulot sur l'échiquier ça
se fait pas tout seul à ses biens et pau
qui peut-être rentrer enfin dans cette
partie mais tu es là quand même claqué
way et 4 quand même du temps
il faut pas se lever la forrest et
ce qu'il dit pour qu'on est clairement
plus de chances de gagner parce qu'il
commence mais en fait c'est un peu ça
on s'est dit ah moi vrai d'ailleurs
parce que avec les normes
d alice très poussée en général ils s'en
sortent très bien et le fait de
commencer ta came petites initiatives
tannique ou de plus donc tu es censé
poser un peu plus de premiers atomes
adversaire après son rouge pas que les
normes plus gagné 6 à partir d'un moment
ils ont égalisé après ils font l'effort
pour essayer de mieux ou clément
prennent trop de risques ou quoi mais en
soi en général à tout le monde
préférerait avoir les blancs tout le
temps c'est si jamais c'était possible
à la question que je pose vraiment c'est
signer pau a réussi pas à gagner
aujourd'hui ce qu'ils sont continuer à
s'entêter où
[Musique]
cela aujourd'hui après cette nuit c'est
vrai qu'il n'a pas eu le temps enfin
admettons que tu veux envoyer une
viennoise par exemple une bêtise tu as
quand même envie de réviser avant
il ya aujourd'hui clairement aujourd'hui
ce n'était pas le jour pour envoyer un
nom mais on met quoi peut-être c'est
juste peuvent 4
faites cesser
4g français 4 qui a fait 3 g 3 enfin un
truc
parce que ça va être moins théorique
plus l'espérance que carlos à nouveau en
général jamais tu as honte a besoin d'un
combat quoi puisque tu as doit regagner
une partie un jour si tu veux en venir
peut-être gagné 2 tu veux gagner donc et
du coes qu'il aurait payé intel ont
dépassé quattro aujourd'hui juste pour
voir chris d'infos
tati natecia est vraiment pas la force
quoi mais bon on va voir enfin là je ne
sais pas pour l'instant s'il ya rien de
ridicule aussi fins moi j'espère qu'ils
reviennent dans le match et très
honnêtement ciné pop gagne aujourd'hui
je suis raide plus heureux du monde on
arrive sarr et égalise sa relance
complètement le match c'est sympa parce
que là le risque qu'on a en réalité on
espère qu'il n'arrivera pas c'est nul
aujourd'hui magnus joue demain en blanc
et lui met la tête sous l'eau et ça
c'est très possible iphone et matchs en
fin du match j'aurai deux points d'écart
se faire du mal ou pour ça que le là on
a besoin entre guillemets d'un dépôt qui
reviennent vite aux minima qui a minima
qui fasse deux nuls pour garder un
intérêt dans le match
par exemple j'en ai pour une partie
contre car il s'agit bien du monde où il
faut forcément passer des semaines
étudié bypass des mois étudiés avant et
après pour les révisions et repasse 4 5
heures le matin
fischer avait commencé son match contre
ce pacs qui à zéro donc tout est
possible a les mêmes joueurs par la même
époque et pas même en deux parties n'est
pas le nom de parti vert
après évidemment tout est possible dans
l'absolu le tour des trois points et
gagner quatre d'affilée et une magie il
attrape le coc vide
non mais bien des cas de figure quand je
dois rester vraiment le cas extrême faim
extrême imagine tu as à une gastro
foudroyante ça est toujours de jouer un
non mais vraiment sans rigoler fasse les
choses qui peuvent arriver un
table du 39 40 de fièvre gastro
foudroyante fort allait tirer les nuls
non mais dans les maladies qui peuvent
arriver via le stress alors le plus de
mots thorax aussi
pneumothorax tu vas pas être bien
tu vas finir à l'hôpital instant teinte
a perdu la partie fin à ces gens même au
delà des échecs il peut ce n'était pas à
l'abri d'un truc pareil
au thorax tu vas pas bien
donc oui oui au delà au delà des échecs
sur six parties aussi si tu tombes
malade tu étais mal en fait
dans ce cas le match serait pas reportée
fait partie du jeu enfin je sais pas ce
que c'est la règle voilà j'ai bien match
bien du portugal
avec son but à 9 là bas ils ont une
équipe ne manque aux visées ça ce
forfait quoi
ils jouent à neuf contre onze en plus
fiables et qui se blesse je crois qu un
homme et un final de l'été en finale de
roland garros on y
arrive mais bon c'est quand j'arrive à
ce moment là mais c'est comme ça
notre avis le csc shoah c'est très chaud
faut vraiment être très stressée à mon
avis mais bon j'ai envoyé un nom de
maladie comme ça
parce que ne pas être les autres est ce
juste la marque
là tout est possible mais juste pour
dire s'il ya deux points d'écart et que
ça se passe plus ou moins normalement
c'est plutôt fini quoi
je pense qu'avec beaucoup de stress
supermarché parce que tu vas voir que la
maladie mais j'imagine que tu peux avoir
des sales trucs je pense tout au long de
tes chansons ouais c'est pas très longue
non mais tu vois je voulais pas citer
infarctus ou quoi c'est pour ça que je
suis allé sur un truc qui me
paraissaient semi grave mais par nortel
jusqu'à pas cool quoi patron
ulcer on le sort de 15 jours est
justement ce thème a nommément
mais ça tu as existe à des saletés tu
parles des trucs au coeur ouais
j'ai voulu éviter
la fiche pas mal moins certain sens on
couche de voir comment qu'elle s'est
appuyé m est ce qu'il fait fausse ici
paraît juste hyper logique mais tu dis
ouais bon peut-être tout racisme ça fait
tout racisme est-ce qu'il tolère ça est
ce que je dis bon le flouze de ce côté
pas trop pourquoi après ce très moche on
baissa de gamme ou où il faut deux
choses le recueil aux 7 kg 6 par par la
ba
balle de set up avec les north est assez
riche en fait ce genre de position donc
assez
bas en cinq minutes
les amis on est de retour e
on n'a rien rater un on n'a rien raté
fab on s'est fait plaisir du jeu plus
beau des abonnés sur neige peu plus au
bon moment
en temps faibles de la partie voiture et
qui a valu sept kg ici soit qui est
logique hein pourquoi pas sauf aux 6
alors après il y aurait une solution par
voire de fugue cascades m'ont proposé
alors en fait ouais bah ils m'ont
proposé un truc est proposé de live sur
ma chaîne en même temps que sur ma
chaîne n'est pas les caméras mais qui
est pas les fûts j'aurais dit non ça
m'intéressait pas mais juste sur et
cette solution pour d'autres
compétitions si vous le souhaitez
mais je trouve que c'est un peu bête
d'avoir les deux live et en même temps
et puis en fait juste pour les trois
minutes où il ya la pub
c'est pas les caméras je ne comprends
pas l'intérêt je pense qu'ils seront
proposés en votre en fait de deux mètres
le live et en même temps sur ma chaîne
de leurs compacts et d'enlever les
caméras parce que j'ai pas les droits et
d'esprit mais deux fois la même chose
ici avec les calmer sur ma chaîne sans
calmer mais du coup ça éviterait des les
pubs voyez donc genre des gens pour être
là sans son
poids en fait avec des caméras ou non
vous serez là bah ouais face pour ça
j'ai pas compris l'intérêt j'aurais dit
non mais
[Musique]
bon pain non j'ai dit que je croyais que
c'était pas une bonne idée by elecam
c'est quand même cool basse et ça c'est
pas quand même de voir plein de choses
qu'on a choisi d'être est de combattre y
aurait eu cette possibilité on va voir
les pubs mais j'aurais dit non je trouve
ça juste stupide je vois pas l'intérêt
pour un mode du on a peut-être pas
d'intérêt s'était tu ailles chercher
mes méthodes les pièces comme ouais mais
c'était pour qu'il n'y ait pas les faux
que sur l'autre chaîne contre ont tenu à
parler mais bon pour trois minutes
par heure ou deux façons il se passe
rien ça me ça me paraissait pas parti de
martine aubry
non mais sans égale en fait on a fait
très souvent sans et on se débrouille
mais bon si elles sont là elles sont là
les rajouter
quand même
devant les cadres un peu les fauteuils
vides les phosagro très heureux
ah oui non et puis là en plus
honnêtement
aaa comme mastercard en fait il ya plus
de pub sur les joueurs que sur twitch
voilà tuer n'importe quelle capitale ait
pu partir hier matin une pub old boys
mastercard unibet note water meltwater
et l'autre cinq cubes en permanence sur
le truc quoi plus bas vite derrière
phosagro trop de partout à des
bouteilles d'eau sur la table et chaises
comme en bas à droite
à huit fûts en permanence quoi as tu as
même si les logos partout en fait ça
c'est fou le logo quoi c'est magnifique
quand je suis très heureux
que moi j'ai un petit requin ici est un
petit requin pas les sharks
très heureux ah bah oui
je pense que le petit
me présente
en
tout cas c'est magnifique
pas déçu sur le téléphone mais bon s'ils
sont du poème de chic bruit pas
peut-être aussi moi je le vois très bien
les chicken à moi aussi et nous on a un
écran plus petit qu'eux et on le voit
très bien
foot il doit réfléchir à ses options de
face on lui fait confiance à magnus
annoncé position seule bosse je pense
que sur terre il ya personne qui est
joue mieux
il a fait 47 peut-être fab libye mais
c'était le coup logique un
nom lucas et se dirige donc vers g6
comme on disait
et quel ange et six blindés il est pas
mal parce qu'il veut venir vers f4 il
tient le centre et savent à quoi
ces 5 1 sur wes que ces cinq maintenant
est-ce que c'est saint caprais kg 6
pouces que jamais ces cinq d'air je sais
pas
ça à l'air de bien aller quand même
tout est bien défendu tout est en place
hormis karpov bien sûr
enfin pour moi car le sel jeu mieux les
espagnols que karkwa finalement il est
juste arrivé 30 ans après donc il a pu
apprendre de karpov et des ordinateurs
donc ils les jouent mieux après toujours
difficile de comparer les époques sans
l'a déjà dit plusieurs fois mais à et si
on prend pas en compte les évolutions et
caetera et qu'on
[Musique]
n'essaye pas de se dire en valeur
actuelle de karpov comment est-ce qu'ils
joueraient magnus est clairement le
meilleur joueur de tous les temps de ces
positions là si on compte pas les
intelligences artificielles
qui sont aussi des formes d'intelligence
savait que via le faz héros stockfisch
sont beaucoup plus forts que magnus mais
si on prend que les intelligence humaine
magnus carlsen est clairement le
meilleur joueur de tous les temps de ces
positions
ah
ça va aller cette
onde et gâte c'est le premier truc bon
propre et juste ne peut présager un
petit fou ou trois ils ont fait 3 c 5
quand même j'aime bien ouais
mais ce que je peux glissade au une tour
à dos en as et peut-être
ce que cisco sur
ces thématiques c'est pour ça que je
pars et je me questionne injuste pour la
cause des saints qui était ton frère du
candidat qu'ils avaient faim qui a
rebondi vers 3 un autre plan avec les
blancs c'est peut-être mais bon j'ai pas
qu'on va faire un clic est carrément g6
essayer de faire f 4 un jour
on s'est quand même bien des cabas faut
revenir mais c'est dur à faire c'est un
truc qui g6 qui viendraient même
on apprend souvent des parties de fisher
ou méfier ce qu'on enseigne des parties
de carl scène ah oui mais c'est
peut-être pour un niveau un peu au
dessus tu commences avec les anciennes
partie parce que c'est plus facile et
puis tu monte en gamme petit à petit
d'ailleurs c'est souvent un bon
un bon contenu de court en fait
logiquement de montrer les vieilles
parties en fait comment le bon plan a
été montré une fois
en face à défendre et pas au top et puis
tu prends une partie jardiner 50-60 un
peu plus tard ou déjà c'était mieux mais
toujours pas à une partie plus moderne
et où on fait finalement le la défense
monte en grade mais peut-être que juste
la pression est quand même trop pourri
et voilà où finalement ça défend mais
c'est dur ou voilà etc mais c'est pas
mal cette approche comme ça parce que je
viens au début vous regardez que des
vieilles parties bah oui
les nouvelles parti un parti plus
récentes elles sont pas
belles sont plus expliquer parce qu'il
ya trop d'ordi donc il ya moins de
logique et prendront des meilleurs coups
en soi mais
c'est facilement expliquant est
explicable pendant là à l'époque
carlos émergents de tous les temps oui
on le moment mais dans dix ans ce sera
probablement un autre joueur qui sera
meilleur que lui et
ainsi va la vie est là et la progression
des échecs sergent c'est un peu comme
une science à ce niveau-là
ça progresse petit à petit la gran d
autres joueurs ce qu'ils ont apporté par
le passé et tout ça quoi
beaucoup de profils actions les partis
actuels qu'on ne peut pas comprendre ou
simple caillou huawei sont troublants
elles sont trop complexes et partis
actuels puis surtout que à vrai dire
même les joueurs dans beaucoup de
parties stu les enfermer dans une pièce
pendant des jours il trouverait pas les
coups qui joue puisque ces écoutes qui
leur sont donnés par les ordis donc
c'est
disons qu'ils sont explicables les coûts
est compréhensible mais ils sont pas
trouvable donc pas reproductible à moins
de les avoir précisément dans la même
position quoi
filosa le dépasse ou c'est déjà trop
tard à bafia roja il est quand même
jeune il a le temps de devenir champion
du monde
tout était explicable après coup pas
tout à fait écologique iphone mais
l'ordinateur tu vas tu vas comprendre
guerre
mais juste c'est les ordinateurs
on va voir ici faut qu' il faut qu'il
trouve un plan avec les blancs mais a
pas l'air d'être vraiment
fière d'avoir obtenu grand chose
peut-être le fou et
3,3
faut trop spaemann je trouve milliards
des options tu doives le fou
3par est cool tu peux aussi c'est
peut-être th2
bon c'est un peu triste cage
c'est sûr que j'ai quatre jours d'un
match 4e place et mais je disais des
fois qu'ils avaient la balle pas mal et
qui a eu trois
un peu tristounet papa génial ouais j'en
ai besoin au prochain e3 probablement
jose gâte mais bon comme c'est de façon
tapageuse vu t'as pas trop envie enfin
t'as pas trop d'idées quoi avec ce qu
il faut 38 donne des tours à cette dame
1 n'est pas le vent à deux
équidés le sait bien bas pourquoi pas
pour faire kf1 qu'il est trop et c'est
même
un peu l'enfant ça va ressembler aux
pillages deux en fait atteint le tour 3
tours f3 peut-être mais bon il a fallu
six d'entre eux aussi
lâché à ce plan tout à l'heure en fait c
est pas fou aussi ce serait fort
c'est
bon on en connaît ses options j'ai
patienté une qui est vraiment plus forte
que l'autre
y alpha 0 réfute la défense française
pas sur un
jeu pas sûr de cette info fab four chat
faut trois paraît logique un vraiment
tourasse est aussi pas être une option
ouais pour provoquer ces cinq il faut le
têt retour à 7 profite du départ du
cavalier
il peut jouer c5 qui revient c'est si tu
repars un peu mais bon au moins une
plongée si
elle fait trois tours à cette série
revient à tour à sept sous et 3 pardon
ils passent autant de temps à fuir ces
des coûts qu'ils connaissent des
ordinateurs bella et s'il est plus dans
la théorie romane
il ne sait plus en fait c'est pas du
doigt
par lui-même livré à lui même après il a
sûrement vu étudié pas mal les positions
qui ressemble donc il peut essayer de
faire marcher des choses qu'il a vues
dans des positions similaires voir
comment ça marchait ce que est ce que ça
marche ou pas ce qui est des détails
différents et ses
4,5 pour rex il a choisi la chaîne
turque contre caruana ben justement
peut-être que tu dit que le mec est
hyper près sûr à l'espagnol qui va avoir
des idées car voilà c'est pas un manchot
non plus tant les dents les espagnols et
la tchèque nikol arrive avec une
surprise en fait le truc aussi c'est que
carlson je parle de berlinoises à
l'époque
et on voit que la note peut être un peu
mise à mal ce parti de maximilian
souvent ou via des petites idées et donc
c'était peut-être pas pertinent d'aller
taquiner fabiano plein fer sur sa prépa
donc là si on arrive déjà comme une
surprise c'est pas mal et s'il a bien
réussi parce que fabiano du coup je vais
la solim au dessus personne était
vraiment prêt avec un nouveau concept
etc il a pas eu de problème vraiment
dessus donc il ya déjà annulé trois
partis noirs après cars car il est venu
en ouvrant la cécilienne c'était plus
que la moitié du match compte que trois
parties et il l'a vient de filer une
fois mais tu as pu éviter aussi la
grosse préparation adverse et donc une
nouvelle fois c'était une manière de
jouer l'adversaire individus plutôt que
voilà comme la con et pau on sent que
des fois il prend décision pour faire
déjouer dépôt à voir donc c'est
intéressant qu'on rapproche quand j'aime
bien
après 400 façon il peut jouer plein
d'ouverture il est fort mais
probablement ce qu'il fait le mieux soit
4,5
ouais
maintenant il a vraiment la bonne
la bonne arme contre eux n'est plus en
plus
il a la bonne arme contre n'est pas
l'envoi aux 4 5 il a joué dans ces
matches contre allende et il l'a joué
contre cardiaque hymne à la joie donc
sur quatre matches sur cinq c'est pas
anodin une fois où il a fait si l'un de
ses thèmes garonne
il arrive avec des idées sur la jeunesse
nikov on arrivait à déjouer les
évaluations des ordis
ouais il a joué avec carré des cinq
après caruana ce qui était une très
bonne idée vous c'est bien sa seconde
est
vraiment une des meilleures manières de
jouer contre d'ailleurs et c'est pas
pour rien que maintenant les noirs quand
il jouait chez sony club seront ils
jouent lors de coups et que le 6 qui
avait eu de cavalli
pour éviter
qu'il y ait des cinq après ça ouvre les
cahiers français 6e 5 ou des trucs comme
ça c'est autre chose mais voilà
ça qui était beau dans ce dernier match
que ça vraiment
vers de nouvelles choses échec ça qui
est intéressant de voir qu'à roanne dans
ces matches là parce que
c'est un joueur vraiment intéressant
avec un de recherche de la vérité quoi
il fait un conte voiture est quoi un
mail l'idée de fautes 3 pam a su se
développer c'est vrai sur ses cinq tours
à 7
un problème sur f5 à venir le truc c'est
ça
dont 10 kgs bouge pas sept points sont
donc faudra d'abord faire fossile ou
d'abord tombé c'est tout je ne sais quoi
mais ouais c'est plus ou moins logiques
quand ils surfent aussi celle qu'il ya
du tout raciste du
voici soit sa rectrice copions ces
bouges
bon rythme en face à la lame en fait
rage imagine notre tour à 8
on leur dit montre un joli truc à la
main 3 6 dames ainsi se trouvaient trois
dames des 5
sur
vitry pas hyper logique dames 1 qu'est
ce qu'on fait
19 17 il suffit pour les blancs mais là
c'est quand même agréable d'affaires du
tmb ça
mais ça va pas suffire
bon tu te fais un peu des trucs et puis
mon va faut jouer
augmenter la pression et tout ça ça le
problème pour battre magnus dans cette
position là c'est qu'il défend bien
aussi après la même si tu gagnes le
premier combat ce qui est déjà très
difficile par un deuxième combat gagné
et même en 3e derrière en fait faut
qu'ils gagnent trois combats d'affilée
vous croyez l'ordinateur aurait pu faire
annuler hier face à carlos annaba
facilement puisqu'il à l'étape de na li
mof donc ils avaient la même pas
quelques justice savait même pas qui a
calculé où ils connaissaient juste les
coups
d'état bof ça a fini le jeu pour
l'instant c'est que jusqu'à cette pièce
petit à petit c'est d'avancer je
revienne un jour neuf etc ça paraît
assez sûr que ça augmente la complexité
à fond c'est très compliqué mais bon on
sait aussi un jour réservé à 32 pièces
je vais finir mais bon c'est dans
longtemps imprimé
sait jamais en fait 5h quantique des
trucs je sais pas je suis pas expert du
truc mais
ça changerait rien de façon bon jouer
maintenant quand je vois rien c'est
juste on soirée conte
même temps huit ou neuf pour arriver je
sais pas peut-être dans dix vingt ans
pour pour les huit pièces faites dans
dix ans
mais bon c'est pas très intéressant non
non non non ce jusque quand tu sais pas
tu allumes le truc et hier on a pu vous
dire que la rance que l'ordi 10 à
empêcher pas compensé avec les pleins
les gagner
réfléchis aussi seulement c'était le
coup et la sylve avoir davantage pense
qu'il faut qu'ils trouvent le tour à six
dames 1 c'est pas simple
qui avait peut-être un jour faut qu'ils
trouvent un truc à elle un couple simple
une fois dans le match jamais un coup
pas simple avons suivi pas simple sans
les ordures on n'aurait pas eu les bons
mots qu'ils fassent
non mais tu peux trouver quand même
introuvable ça quand même autre nom mais
c'est dur mais c'est pas non plus c'est
pas les trucs les plus durs que j'ai vue
dans ma vie après je sais pas quel point
leur avantage même bon ok + 0 5
occasions voilà donc je vais vous dire
je peux monter vos la profondeur
question c'est ce qui va se rasseoir
avant la prochaine pub fab ah ouais
c'est pas clair et un suspense
à toi aussi
4 évidemment
dans les tours à six avaient vraiment
l'air cool
terrasson
mais disons tout raciste différentes
manières de jouer quoi quand même un
coup c'est la bonne direction en retour
assistera vite dames 1
tout reprend me prends tu es fou prend h
3o le problème d'un professeur j'imagine
bon mais ce que
l'on fait c'est 6 par exemple dame bouge
le fonds est de là-bas
bon
non plus aux fins
on joue quoi
donc je sais pas je sais pas si c'est
mieux tour à 6,6 et mieux des 4 dans
tous les cas il va rien à voir
d'extraordinaire faut vraiment jouer une
partie longue quoi tu apparais
ccem bien fou ces deux puits des canes
d'accord
validé deux des quatre gars dans les
cases blanches peut-être peut-être c'est
mieux
qu'ils aient forcé c'est quoi ils
diffusent ces deux des quatre je sais
pas je vais aller voir mais c'est ce
qu'on dit dans le château mais je viens
aux eyzies d-4d 4 0 15
tours à 6h25 face et des petits scores
tous les coups sûrs un point de mieux
mais c'est pas énorme mais c'est déjà
pas mal en fait barça je veux dire avec
les blancs
c'est déjà un petit truc
enfin on attend le prochain coup on
refait une petite pub euh ok bah si
c'est bon je pense ouais c'est pas
réfléchir il va chercher ce qu'on
faisait de son décathlon tour à six
tours à cette
réponse après la pub peut-être oui à la
suite les amis
pavon est de retour yoyo à la fine fleur
il s'est passé le d4 qu'on attendait à
vrai dire il était dans les deux trois
coups qu'on avait
depuis bombay
on va avoir un humaniste l'air bien
claqué six
hommes et non un coupon bout de tours à
huit salaires logique quoi et c'est pour
ça qu'on les fait retour à 6 ans fait
lui tu te mets en face
sachant ça change quoi c'est sympa
l'esprit se donnent des 3c 6 10 ça va je
suis en place quand
même
très difficile
c'est une des options sur des quatre bon
peut-être l'option de freud et eux
décédés kg si c'est ouf ou b3 dame b 3
kg s'ils souhaitent être attaque 4 après
un peu ses arriérés en échange
ok ça joue aussi un
des deux ou trois peut-être les montants
à la case f4 ouais non bon repas c'est
clairement une option pour les deux
qu'on vient de voir ces deux options je
sais pas manquer la mieux les deux sont
jouables
et avoir quoi
tu vas jouer la gagne et je pense bon il
ya deux bonnes options
qui lui donne à une pression proche de
l'égalité après avoir laquelle il a
préféré comme
on dit par ailleurs adapte sur la
position de magistris mais
celui-ci tout à 6,6 l'année peau
prochain sur pied en prend il fait fou
g5 + entre angers et ça ça change pas
que les blancs avaient une toute petite
pression avant et que et les normes ont
gagné la position là une vérité
fondamentale et après mais pour yariv a
quand même fait beaucoup de cas font le
objet de se répéter du coup mais
mais à ce niveau là t'es pas censé faire
autant d'erreurs grossières
donc après des cas peut-être tours à
huit est te prends des quatre peut-être
même ses 6
j'aimerais passer sa mère en
anticipation de tous à
[Musique]
tour à huîtres est le plus logique après
s'il fait des machins la pression sur
quatre c'est plus compliqué mais ça
palermo veine mais quand même à faire un
peu les blancs
l'autre avec tour est vite ça m'a l'air
s'améliore normal
en plus j'ai envie de dire dans les
jours comme ça où tu es un peu sous
pression après la partie d'hier c'est
tellement agréable de jouer une position
que tu sais que je joue bien ça mais
tellement en confiance
car tu sais que tu es fort tu sais que
tu as la bonne position tu as le bon
feeling et tu sais que tu peux jouer
aussi un peu avec la main et ça doit
passer quoi c'est vraiment rassurant
ouais voilà qu'en témoin clé de faire
les gros efforts de réfléchir à fond ben
de pouvoir faire confiance à son
instinct
oui ça c'est vraiment un point
positif aussi pour magnus après
attention on n'est pas à l'abri d'une
surprise on n'est jamais à l'abri d'une
erreur aux échecs elle est si vite
arrivé je demande faute
et on voit un petit peu comme hier il ne
lâche pas ses coûts en bonbons il sait
ce qu'il va faire mais je crois qu'ils
redoublent tchèque
derrière ça aurait pu lui lui coûter
cher si c'est cher leur maison
et il s'est hissé retrouvé à faire d'eux
des erreurs on va dire des grosses 0 à
des grosses erreurs calmes aux siens
moins grosse conne et paumé il s'est mis
à rater des choses aussi lui pas
forcément à cause de la pression est
plus du manque de temps attention ne pas
réitérer la même la même faute pierre
ce serait dommage
bon je prends cinq six jours ouais il
devrait peut-être éviter de se mettre
avec une minute pour 5 ou iphone edf et
erdf et ben pas mal de très intéressant
ce serait pas de bol
pour lui remettre ma l'otan ouais pour
les branchés de droit commun du coup
puisque sur fion prend il va nous faire
tomber trois ans allemand et kg 6 dans
la foulée
ouais
c'est pas mal quand même le jeu d'échecs
si tu calcules tout c'est un jeu sans
hasard mais comme sa part et des
milliards d'années pour faire ça un
humain ou un ordi c'est un jeu où il ya
quand même une du hasard quand tu vas
des variantes non calculée qui te font
gagner ou fournil exactement à ce record
il ya du beau lui aux échecs aussi parce
qu'on ne peut pas on ne peut pas tout
calculer on peut pas tout voir et dans
les variantes qu'on n'a pas vu il faut
le beau lui que ça marche
a pressé de le réduire au mieux mais
par mon sang pour sang
il devrait allonger un peu les cadences
ouais c'est vrai qu'il ya avec une
cadence plus longuement parlé hier soir
un fabre n'est pas aurait peut-être pu
de fer d'abaisser chaque année
l'occasion des quatre il y avait encore
de la défense si on avait joué dans les
anciennes cadence avec une heure de
rajouts tous les vingt coups mais
pourrait eu de vraie chance de la sauver
avec le raccourcissement de la cadence à
a coûté a coûté cher à l'epo sur un sur
la partie d'hier
il avait pu avoir le
jour normalement ouais tu te fais une
nuit entière à apprendre les tables
basses parker
peut-être tu avais une chance aussi
ouais
six epr en cavale et prend s'éprend
pourquoi elle tient ses promesses en
plus logique
allait prendre répond peut-être pas
mauvais mais
reste un client français mais ça va lui
ce n'est pas si mal
cette heure de jeu ça vous suffit pas à
ralentir la cadence on merci ben
non parce qu'en fait déjà ses
connaissances plus traditionnel salut tu
rajoutes tous les vins coup et c'est
quand même on vous des longs cadence
juste on pourra pas voir trop d'erreurs
et on a vu hier en plus que même les
deux heures sur les 40 premiers coups ça
suffisait pas peut-être qu'il faudrait
mettre deux heures et demie voire 3 à
direct
c'est quoi le souci sur fou prend
ça doit jouer aussi mais ouais pourquoi
pas mais juste on fout et pas forcément
bien placé
après d'amnesty site menace sûrement
fourrage 3 n'en fasse un truc contre
bajaur voilà vous voir prendre tellement
évidemment le cavalier plutôt raide le
fou à perdre du temps hier soir cali c6
ou sur ces 5 et qui est si fier hier
vers 5 et c'est donc le fauve est il est
bien s'il est stable ou si tu avais pas
le pion ses trois plus reculées ou je
sais pas quoi là c'est rien de grave
pour les blancs mais c'est sûrement pas
optimale
non c'est pas optimalisation
aidé à me prend
par françois faire un fou
mais pour être bien sûr
vu qu'on avait regardé toutes les autres
primes mais non mon général d'ailleurs
c'est pas une mauvaise chose d'arriver
un peu toutes les possibilités mais bon
après on va savoir tu peux éliminer
assez vite mais en partie en vrai on le
fait un
barreau c'est souvent bien de déterminer
les coûts candidat donc c'est les coups
possibles on en a trois j'imagine ces
cdd 4 qui est des 4es faut analyser les
3 et choisir celui qui a aussi ses
actions progressent après et choisir du
cool là ce qui nous plaît le plus en
comparant notre évaluation de chaque
variante ne faut pas crier au hasard le
premier convoi
je suis à caen avec le boss du 20e geek
la beauté de ces partis c'est justement
que quand tu les regardes après dans dix
vingt ans et que tu les revois certes
elles sont longues la regarder en direct
mais après ce sont des belles parties à
revoir et c'est vrai que par rapport à
ça c'est un peu décevant est fière
d'avoir eu ce manque de temps plusieurs
fois dans la partie qui a créé des
erreurs et qui fait que la partie qu'on
a vu hier on la regarde en disant on dit
c'est une mauvaise partie alors que si
il y avait eu une heure de plus voire
deux avant le 40e coup quand on revoit
la partie il aurait peut-être une partie
parfaite
ouais
complètement
c'est complètement le cas
à une épaule sera à lui de jouer il ne
revient pas saluer vraiment coûté la
game hier enfin sans rigoler je sais pas
mais on fait une connerie en fait c'est
incroyable les petits nous qu'on lui
dise pas quoi
à
votre caméra public
très heureux
ça vient de personne nulle part
ne venait pas d' arbitrer c'est pourquoi
y'a juste personnes
veulent que mme hermans et ça me fait
penser à soho est ça w le film ouais
j'aurais sans les décrit des caméras ils
vont devoir s'attacher à trouver des
gens pour voir sortir pour jouer
magnifique non
à jean-michel un cadrage on va voir un
peu la salle
et personne n'y a personne y a personne
au premier rang
génial ya vraiment juste personne quoi
ces boucles
le deuxième rang personne
magnifique en fait
je crois qu'il ya quelques gars
troisième manche
ça a pas l'air d'être la foule ça
détonne quoi un puck l'aurès alors on
voit leur téléphone en fait non ils sont
sur leur téléphone est de trois garçons
à défaut qui marche
vraiment pas grand monde
malaise
magnifique adverse bien maxime aussi je
prends aujourd'hui
il vient il s'assied
et s'éprend d'un bond le plus cain
way jouer
ils se parlent entre eux m
c'est plus marrant quand y'a personne on
aime bien
pim vous promettre un nom pour revenir
devant vos plans larges et quand même
toit et vapeur à l'entraîneur mais en
fait je repère encore humide faire un
jardin c'est à y recourir il revient
mais bon t'as perdu vraiment 30 secondes
je veux tempo silva noté avant un an et
reprend tempo
non mais bon
tu mérite pas d'être champion du monde
quand tu fais ça en fait juste ici
s'imagine erwin heger six jouets
qu'ils méritent pas d'être champion du
monde
avec kg 6 sur quoi s'enchaînent bas sur
plusieurs choix sont des champions sont
va attaquer ces sept en
jeu c'est peut-être dame puis pas quoi
l'âme des trois dames ces deux dom
dessein est de retour à saint lô c'est
un
[Musique]
tu peux te lever quand l'agresseur fou
prend b3
parce que je sais pas
s'il a vraiment bien je encore une fois
tranquillou qu'est-ce qu'il est fort
dans ses positions
franchement je suis admiratif
on joue bien puis bon
il faut pas prendre
fois de plus
on vous aime pas c'est que c'est pas un
par rapport à des postes c'est vraiment
pour lui je me répète mais c'est
vraiment pour lui prix peut il pas
rester debout pendant une heure ci veut
c'est
son droit au trône où est son droit mais
tu veux dire que ce que tu reproches le
plus un peu ces latitudes et sa façon de
jouer sur l'échiquier ou sa préparation
bat en fait c'est un tout c'est pas
dissociable l'inde et l'autre quoi
non mais après pour le coup sa voiture
qu'il était ultra serré dans sa
préparation il a fait des efforts
physiques il a perdu un peu de poids il
s'est mis en forme tant qu'il a pu il a
travaillé comme un ouf le fait de gagner
les candidats c'est pas anodin c'est
pendant de la merde qu'il a fait ça donc
donc il a beaucoup bossé mais
pour aller atteindre carlson c'est
encore le truc au dessus
il s'appelle conviendront suffisant et
deux dans sa prépa ou tu le fait qu'ils
étaient sérieux il n'a peut-être pas été
bien conseillés ou la plus proche la
bonne stratégie s'il s'en faire danser
espagnol et qu'à la fin la grinta une
grand
ouais ça va faire vraiment là il s'en
faire et là lui ils ont dans tout le
match il aura sept blanc là c'est déjà
la quatrième
j'ai bien peur de vous dire que après
plus de cinquante personnes parties
blanches en gagner une
et donc
il n'a pas obtenu une position n'a pas
l'air 300 comme idée quoi on pouvait
s'en douter de base ça ça confirme un
peu qu'on ait des doutes
merci péquenots karpov
guéniot carbone
attaquer on peut le défendre par daems
et 2 mai sa palme il est bien loin non
bah je pense peut faire c'est 5
échange massif
alors
comme ça
et là j'avais pas trop les données
option en fait ça serait mieux pour les
besoins on peut peut-être défendre mais
il faut pas rentrer là dedans c'est un
peu confus
et ce que y'a pas moyen de faire mieux
comme c2c 5 bon si les pacéens qui a
passé cinq conseils qu'on a envie de
faire vous prend tour s'est vite b4
acheter une pression
alors ça c'est peut-être pas qu'on cache
trois mosquées de 6
j'ai surtout l'impression qu'il a voulu
faire du kayak ina n'est pas un mais
c'est bien ton tu perds pas mais le truc
c'est que right in quand même cinq
meilleurs défenseurs caennais pourquoi
oui non mais je voulais dire dans la
stratégie avant l'impression que il fait
du kayak in san attirail akin il joue
pas sur ses forces
non mais bon truc c'est que
bon il en est hier où la deuxième serait
plus aux minorités mais il n'a pas fait
d'appel aurait pas gagné en blanc mont
blanc non noire en fait sa stratégie
elle est bonne en fait
mais en blanc c'est pas toi qui domine
tu subis
ces lignes blanches contre noir
c'est pas maintenant qu'il en a perdu
avec les noirs du coup tu dois adapter
ce que tu fais avec les bleus aussi
villa il semblerait pas qu'ils adaptent
grand chose
fo qui rit du bo lui
une gaffe est vite arrivé mais là oui
car le sel qui à l'orfèvre quand même il
a trouvé les bons coups et étapes sur
quatre est
[Musique]
normand plus la dame s'est dotée pas
trop de ces cinq faire confiance mais
peut-être juste damas at on fait
des français cette attaque 4
ouais c 50 du
mal à voir comment un problème
vincent ce que ça donne tourbe et 8
visuellement tu dis ça va pas être
terrible terrible mais en fait ça tient
quoi
bon si tu le joues deux fois ceux qui y
croient
une fois on peut dire bon et dribble il
fait de messire par dessus ces chrétiens
et que ces cracks
et surtout ça veut aussi dire que
l'équipe de dépôt n'a rien trouvé
parce que sinon ils auraient pris
davantage ouais bon il ya peut-être
juste rien à prouver juste du coup mais
ouais mais c'est bizarre de s'en faire
une entreprise à savoir un jeu vient
après là ils ont peut-être pas eu le
temps enfin l'équipe oui mais n'est pas
peut-être pas eu le temps de
mais ça aurait pu aussi être une bonne
journée pour tenter un petit truc
qui te dit qu'il a 23 880 points de
chaîne à quoi ça sert à rien parce que
je pensais mais
c'est à dire
tu peut on faire un petit truc les
filets quelqu'un pour ça lui serve à
rien à l'autre ou
non non tu as des points c'est tout
c'est ça pas mal mais
bon ça écrire en mauve ok c'est pas mal
[Musique]
j'essaie de me demander si j'ai une
autre idée mais non
il ya peu de pièces un peu comme
hymne de génie ce qui crée mon move
c'est magnifique ça ne sert absolument à
rien non monsieur de sucre
puis à monsieur
viol était de
penser j'en serais content si ça leur
part été esquivé les pubs un peut-être
et ben non ça ne sert plus à rien
rien rien n'est fait bah oui tellement
de messages de plaintes entre guillemets
qu on se dit bon
c'est mieux qui a rien
voudrais rien c'est beaucoup mieux et
vous c'est mieux que rien la pub oui bah
oui - tu vas la pub la plus beau de les
voir c'est cool
ça rend la pub sexy
deux fois rien c'est toujours rien mais
trois fois rien c'est déjà quelque chose
pas même son
épaule qui maintenant réfléchi il ya
plus rien à prouver
ouais ça va
ça va aller dans la turbo drôle j'ai
l'impression qu'on prédisait en amont
n'appartenait on craignait même
[Musique]
pour ceux qui avaient encore d'autres
pourriez vous faire un résumé de la
situation qui domine barbe personne
enfin personne domine la donc une partie
plutôt l avantage de carlson du coup
puisqu'il mène 1-0 dans le match mais à
proprement parler aujourd'hui personne
ne domine non pas même ouest les sauts
ce qui est rare
mais
web os au coût de ces espagnols qu'on en
a déjà vu trois précédemment crest et la
quatrième
des toujours un peu les mêmes voire
d'anti marshall
s'est même pas grand chose pour
l'instant pour dépôt
vous êtes à le marché de noël du coup
non mais ça près mais c'est dur parce
qu'avec reagan troll pas sanitaire le
samedi de là que tout aille avons une
heure de course a semblé tf1 c'est
l'enfer équatoriale et le mardi matin un
compte sur personne on a fait la
dernière fois
que là c'est vraiment vraiment difficile
de rentrer
ses longs quoi
nordique à 5 degrés avec le vent pareil
france c'est pas la peine nous on fait
pas quoi
si la pâte que ça va
en revanche le mardi matin c'était cool
quand on est allé y
avait une partie qui était fine d'une
vite la petrov ou quoi ouais déjà petite
fille at elle et toi c'était bien
c'était sympa 17h10 voilà oui il ya des
jours et des créneaux plus sympa que
d'autres non là ça me dit samedi 10 à 18
heures
c'est dur
alors que c'est l'heure de la pub fab a
comparé du marché donc on se retrouve
dans cinq petites minutes les amis en
espérant avoir un un coup un coup un
coup donné position qui semble déjà
rejoint sans vie ouais
a tout de suite
on est de retour les amis
vous tenir au courant sur ce qui s'est
passé dans la partie mais ce qu'on peut
vous dire c'est que les castrés mène
mais 10 à 3 fab
plaisir
qui font un bon match contre le racing à
domicile
c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien
et donc une épaule lui qui a fait tout
re c'est un tueur est allé à l'est le
seo qui part aller castres
ça va attaquer ces 7
mai donc
[Musique]
cette possible de faire 34 7 tours sète
ou deuxième option
de telles femmes osent aux saisines
cauet
cécile cau ar rahman ben tu fais pas ton
point 4 ans et scelle j'imagine on a tu
peux vouloir tu reviens au set mais bon
ça va
ouais ça passe
bon faut traire plus fort en fait
de signer
avec l'idée
dé prend des profs ou prendre et le
travail f4
non
j'ai plus vite que lui sait pas si on
leur prend surtout pas qu'ils traitent
bien que le café des 2 tours fc
peut-être relief quattro menace
fourchette au
hall 2 rien ne menace pas qu'ils
éprouvent à froid puisque la dame couvre
t d'or en 2
h 2 peut-être comme j ce
match
porte qui claque un truc qui ne va pas
bien on va fermer la fenêtre fab
ouais
il a envoyé ces signes qu il a envoyé le
6 inco
en fait de base c'était prévu qu'on
fasse des pauses injuste les gens
comprennent pas de base en fait c'est
prévu qu'on fasse dix minutes de pause
toutes les heures mais juste de faire
c'est sympa de voir les fermes et vous
on a vu que par l'allemand par
gentillesse intéressait pas trop mais
c'était par gentillesse qu'on le faisait
mais
vu que c'est pour se faire tacler qu' on
est gentil
on peut faire un truc normal mais le
normal on profite de notre pause et puis
c'est cool pour nous au final c'est cool
hein
au final c'est cool
tu as tes autres hormones tacle ou pas
enfin on verra
oui on a le droit à la pause toutes les
heures de 10 minutes normalement c'est
prévu pour
justement on ne faisait pas parce qu'on
met en vrai on aurait peut-être dû le
faire dès le premier jour 1
voilà vraiment
enlever tous les soucis de la position
bien joué ces cinq quand même c'était
pas si simple de trouver mais pour lui
voilà il a très bien joué très bonne
partie mais pour rien d'injuste bailly
continue dans cette voie qui lui donne
pas grand chose
voilà ça risque passerait aujourd'hui
comme prévu on a toujours su
navré les joueurs eux aussi prennent des
poses faut dire qu'il se passe quand
même le truc avec ses 5 ans on l'avait
depuis
faut le faire marcher vous bien le
calcul est donc maintenu celui d'amiens
mais vous allez voir la vente 707 bouffe
bouffe
et froides aux menaces fourchette donc
les bleus ont fait un truc comme
hongrois h 2 quoi d'objets 6 menace
maths et h4 et des dieux
l'a43 fit m&f
3.3 kg épreuve 3
rémy des fois je table à cenon des frais
y en a qui m'ont dit rémi
rémy baïkal en russie mais rémi ses
parents russes ou en allemand en plus ça
ce n'est de charbon allemand et rémy ans
et celui d'aujourd'hui
dont kim chi chi vinh ouais ouais c'est
gai c'est ta place et mais par contre le
truc c'est quand tu dis on fait nul qui
remet pas t on pas tes patins partager
ses les castrais ouais les castrer ouais
c'est nicolas il est bon c'est leur 8e
bien les gars ça fait 4 ça fait face à
faire un petit set à 3
sur une belle série là entre deux amis
tombent en bord de la
regarde
hélas oui très énervé il va prendre le
ballon
l'impact violent très fort bien bien
bien avancé
ouais non là c'est déjà à turbo trop je
pense
orne le 10 sport on est un peu de
partout en fait le truc c'est qu'on a le
tennis en commun fable le foot ou le
rugby mais j'aime le rugby mais je suis
beaucoup moins experts j'aime bien
jamais regardé la grèce est beau quand
même ce qu'il a dit ben j'ai vu le duff
est le premier il a encaissé l'impact il
s'est décalé
mais n'avance vraiment
absolument il repasse un quatrième
ralentissement ils sont heureux quoi
il a perforé la performance
n'est pas un peu de ça aussi pour
réveiller une épaule
faudrait qu'à hervé de l'impact là
on voit du bon score 24 patch dans
l'équipe puis allez fois puis
à risque est à lienz à jouer en tant que
débutant le monde chaque achat ou charge
tout se joue après en tant que débutant
ou te prendre trop la tête avec deux
ouvertures fait un truc normal tu
développes tu prends le somptueux rock
etc ça serait prolong du temps mieux
investis se perd 3 palestine s'est fait
plaisir en général faire des ouvertures
symétrique 4,5 ou des quatre des cinq
plus facile pour commencer en tout cas
facile à gérer comment tous les enjeux
ou quoi mais bon
pas tout se joue n'importe quand si
jamais tu as envie
aux frais qu'il y ait des avants j en
reviens dans son équipe
non c'est frustrant en tant que
spectateur
de quoi allécher sud non non le
petit slippery quoi
alors vraiment revoir le plan large l'a
peut-être
j'aime bien son large allée magnifique
ian eames et carlson qui gagne au
ralenti à nul c nul mais ça arrange car
le scène en fait c'est le match est loin
d'être finie il dure dans le mans 14
parties vous produire à la fin mais
quand tu mènes au score ben mouaïa de
partis ou safa était pas pu avancer vers
l'objectif
quand même ses plans larges rabats ce
magnifique
ya plus nos caméras mais bon c'est pas
grave
on nous entend il faisait important
c'est magnifique
c'est l'événement phare des échecs il a
lieu une fois tous les deux ans
mais l'année politique c est mort pour
aujourd'hui
ya toujours ce marivaux même qu'il fasse
gaffe il faut qu'il fasse nul vite
maintenant il est capable de s'en
prendre une petite
hier la plus grande partie de l'histoire
des championnats du monde après victoire
de magnus à la fin du marathon c'est
exactement ça
ce que tu en es 4,1 oui mais ils veulent
bouffer ce film là le truc c'est que ça
obligerait donc
ce que vous arrivez à jour à dubaï mais
sûrement ils ont payé pour un tout
bêtement un
bond de 5 intéressant
c'est très intéressant mais moins ils
regardent pas dans la ligne toute simple
tu as tu le prends dans ses réseaux
n'avions pas c'est intéressant ok
choix
intéressant comme tu le disais au prom
bon je passe ici grave parce que des
noirs peuvent faire ou quatre mais ça
complique le jeu a tout d'un coup
qu'avec 1,05 en d3 et d4 france et 5
malheureusement tout reprend
oui j'ai l'impression que la tour et on
s'est dit pourquoi pas qui a été quatre
alors au probant pourquoi pas mieux que
pas d'autre qui va arriver un jour je
réagis tu es sûr qu'il faut prendre ces
cinq si jamais son carburant sont mieux
la
bonté autour des 80 ans pourchassé
et qu'elle prend b 5 à 4,1 tonnes de
maïs
au tour de tous les sacs à sainte
justine offre t'attaques le roi après 1
mais le seul truc à dire c'est que aussi
sur cinq n'est pas du tout sur des
preuves
de bouger la main
et comme ça s'il ya des cdc
vois tu peux prendre ça mais c'est 4
ouais c'est ça est bon parce que mieux
probablement meiway des français des
français on sait 5,35 à ça ça retombe
dans la simplicité le gardien a tout
intérêt à rentrer là dedans plutôt que
l'autre
bon des changes ton
texte
juste rien
notamment ces quatre échanges
oued un f5 ou séparés probable
ouais
y'a pas pas vraiment d'autres options et
la même 5 peut être éclairer un
letra d'eau etc les radeaux
c'est un rachat peut être présentée
comme numéro un mondial sans être tape
un du classement fidh
patapam du classement fidh en fait c'est
pas un titre 1 ces deux choses
différentes et a le classement fidh la
fin de classement mondial à rio mais qui
a pas grande valeur et il ya le titre de
champion du monde
mais c'est pas la même chose en fait non
ces deux choses distinctes
après bon le truc c'est très souvent le
no 1 mondial à un best-of qu'il était
champion du monde parce qu'ils jouaient
mieux que les autres mais mais c'est pas
c'est pas obligatoire
il a fait de même 5 ouais ouais
d'ailleurs je veux dire qu'arsène
basse a fait lui échappe également été
nuls ramenés à lepuix de 2011 verrait
son titre et 2 en 2013
et à sa qualif pour les jeux de 2013
c'était très très chaud je joue et
je sais pas en fait la taille le film
prend exactement fait avec rami et donc
je sais pas pourquoi sont départagées
tes meilleurs ou quoi sinon je disais
pas fait de match d'ailleurs je pense
aurait même pu même à oui un petit
rapide ou quoi d'accord ça ne va pas
gagner mais bon ce sera mérité ça quand
même mais du coup il a très bien pu ne
pas gagner ces candidats là c'est à deux
doigts et à ce moment là bas ils
rataient pas champions cette fois là et
qu'il sera devenu toyota en fait un but
comme il est au dessus mais il aurait pu
peut-être pendant cinq grandes voire
mondiale sans être champion du monde
entre temps
complètement
ça devrait changer maintenant
c'est vrai qu'il peut tenter ces dames
des cinq
hockey
l'idée c'est bien sûr déjà décédées
et six au fait j'en prends des quatre
dom prend cinq
ans a
indiqué d'ailleurs que ouais mais bon en
fait c'est compliqué c'est une quinzaine
aussi a perdu la dernière
c'est un cas de figure où on fait
terme 100 secondes se vident leur je
crois et kramnik jeu contre ils vont de
choc grave ni qu'avaient les noirs
quinte scène j'ai eu quelques couleurs
il
lancé lorsqu'il avait des blancs comme
ça il appert vite et en vo bon au crâne
et qu'il est un peu dans la merde comme
tu le dis car cette blanche combinent
leurs va perdre quoi
faire peut-être faire nul il va
peut-être me gagner s'ils gagnent bravo
à lui toute façon je peux rien y faire
mais bon il a la pression faut qu'ils
fassent mais donc moi je peux pas enfin
je parle mokrani qu'avec les noirs je
peux pas je veux un truc insipide où ils
voient que je vais faire qu'au nul ici
rue se passe rien de grave tout le
bordel il a joué une pire que tu as un
truc compliqué pour eux car ça ne puisse
pas se dire nati se passe peut-être
gagner ni à perdre je peux pas gérer je
dois jouer la partie mais je veux pas
trop prendre de risques il n'a pas eu
tous porter attention imploser
complètement en plein vol et créé à
munich ballon du coude en jeu le truc
risque et certains des contrats vie mais
c'était la bonne stratégie en fait juste
bon voilà ils vont en tout cas fait une
bonne partie alors qu'ils faisaient
n'importe quoi tout le temps il a perdu
trois parties en tombant autant les
portes
bah c'est juste pas de chance pour
kramnik genre limite sa seule bonne
partie du tournage a été celle là mais
c'est comme ça quoi
et voilà donc c'était gros suspense et
c'était vraiment un beau tournoi des
candidats peut-être le meilleur j'ai pu
voir quoi jean linder
ça jouait vraiment bien son voyage une
gros suspense et bien
voilà aujourd'hui
terminée voilà ouais on pas de marché de
noël mais peut-être une petite balade en
ville on va voir quoi
chocolat chaud ah ouais peut-être
intéressant
c'est on va retrouver la fromagerie pour
aller reprendre de la table noisette
adhérents bien je pourrais en plastique
atteint mode est toujours jeter un peu
d'huile à lui on n'a pas essayé mais
table mowjcamp ramener chez toi un
extraordinaire
tu as vu nous a dit la prochaine fois
vous en prenez une demie
il a toujours su se reprendre une
entière voilà oif a roulé pour revenir
au delà du sein
de dia les terribles
demandant d'être inquiète on va pas
s'envoler lui dit ne t'inquiète pas
ah oui non je compte bien rester sur les
appuis
c'est vraiment une partie insipide
aujourd'hui mais bon c'est logique ouais
non mais en fait juste magnus a vraiment
bien viens jouer quoi ah oui ah oui oui
oui la manui felli fait une très bonne
partie un
correspondant qui contrairement à hier
pour le coup oui il avait la partie de
ma guise est beaucoup plus aboutie
aujourd'hui qu'hier c'est une partie
très abouti
bravo à lui un ouais
evidon qui gagne mais voilà ça va faire
nul invraisemblable on a montré qu'il
n'y a plus de vie dans la position en
fait qu'à 5 août lourdeur france et 5
aussi intéressant je sais pas toi tout
reprendre cinq passes qui menacerait
découverte voilà donc a priori les
blancs on va changer
extraordinaire c'est une belle variante
bon pied repas répété tout le temps mais
non il n'a pas vu je vais mal avant le
contrôle du temps pour te retrouver mal
avec les blancs après trente coups c'est
que tu as mal joué aussi avant en fait
bah oui
voilà à part habiter le même truc à
chacun qu'un maire d'auvers son truc en
tchat en fait le problème c'est que les
gens nous écoutent les vidéos de les
gens disent que c'est extraordinaire que
c'est bien joué et qui font pas de
l'analyse pas faim et du coup après il
croit sa peinture ça vient pas d'eux
qu'ils arrivent en fait le problème mais
bon dans un conte pire ils vont en
particulier les jours et c'est le 50e à
regarder un truc écrire sur internet
journée où il n'a raté que dame si ce
n'est pas où ils vont pas t'expliquer
avec la finale tu dois pas rentrer
dedans ils vont pas dit fier le fameux
14 rené paul dumais mans on compte de
presse mais
c'est psioniques
aujourd'hui en tout cas ce mois-là sait
très bien ce qu'il veut car oui c'est
une très bonne partie de ma niche
reste à finaliser ses 17 minutes
complètement un
amour ces paumés easing patients mais
c'est juste bien jouer
c'est très propre quoi aujourd'hui c'est
très propre
c'est dommage ouais c'est juste dommage
qu'on ait pas de son fait là dedans mais
les choix qui s'y fait ça cette fois
c'est contre cette fois la propreté
[Musique]
ouais c'est malheureux mais c'est comme
ça
hier il gagnant gagnant mais vous le
trouvez mauvais regard la partie en fait
déjà il ya une pâle ingagnable et mieux
et n'est pas où il fait
bon se résumer
à cette chance et que tu as des gens qui
posent la question au début puis
d'autres yade deux heures après car 19e
truc faut être là au début écouter en
fête ou à les écouter dans une mise sur
youtube ça c'est bien aussi
vous n'aurez pas ton t t 4 dont
peut-être ses quatre
bleus prennent deux des quatre c'est que
c'est très très très large c'est parce
que cassano de jouer et c'est choquant
ces quatre c'est un peu plus restreint
et peut-être qui peut plus facilement le
jouer sans être totalement experts ou
d'autres trucs si mr
will est il en crise parce qu'il reste
que trois parties que s'ils jouent un
coup il sera pas où ça va le temps qu'il
ouvre une carte non
il est pas bien l'année
poney poney mais aussi pour l'aspect
notre candidat
mais je ne sais pas si lui beaucoup de
4,5 je pense qu'il a battu ding avec
l'espagnol oui si je me souviens bien je
pense que la première moitié du menu
tournoi
et jouer avec détroit cette partie là
vite au tour
donc mais c'est pas un point de
l'espagnol en soit en fait une très
bonne ouverture même si tu es l'espagnol
compte carmes scène exclusivement
surtout quand tu as vu qu'en fait tu tu
avais rien tu peux quand même tester et
voir une fois deux fois à bon moment
ce qui me gêne pas bref plein de france
qu'il laisse la place ça fait longtemps
qu'ils jouent plus alors il joue je suis
en france par équipe quelques parties
avec son club mais je reviens de france
individuel saf
faire quasiment dix ans qu'il ne fait
plus
surtout les championnats du monde jouée
par karl scène pour le moment le calice
adversaire est le plus proche de le
faire tomber à kariat keane
dans un match assez étrange un rôle à
carla scène dominé vraiment de la tête
et des épaules et a raté les gagner en
fait il avait dû enfin c'est pas qu'ils
ratent essai qui tombait dans des sur
des défenses
incliné il a fait un peu disjoncter quoi
les du goût karim ben guerdane à force
de voir absolument gagner après trop de
risques qui se
sont le palais on va dire tout seul car
et qu'il mène 1-0 et bon magnus arrive à
égaliser difficulté mais y arriver
et c'est le départage après l'autre ma
seconde caruana
bon 12 parties 12 nuls donc là encore
car henin était très près aux mêmes
rennais envier sur le match mais on peut
pas dire carrément été proche de gagner
non plus juste fait jeu égal mais carac
income et menés au score en grade 2
parties de la fin à trois parties de la
fin
c'est pour ça qu'on dirait qu'ils n'ont
plus proche mais caruana a été très bien
aussi
maintenant il y en a gagné une manif va
viser des turbos d'euros il va vouloir
creuser non je pense qu'avec les blancs
il va continuer la même stratégie après
finalement les meilleures chances de
gains sont peut-être au noir pour un
dépôt c'est assez paradoxal
henry l'a probablement mais il a plus de
chances de perdre
or noir mais il a peut-être plus de
chances de gagner parce qu'avec les
plans
c'est vraiment insipide 1
ouais où il changera conférence livre
si manu son organe une avec les blancs
et c'est terminé
s'il gagne la prochaine il reste combien
de partis derrière six valeurs mamie
match sont donc s'ils gagnent au moins
il aurait 6
parce qu'il a perdu une partie que c'est
fini annonce est pas finie mais le
joueur qui est favori maintenant plus
mais non plus et on sait qu aux échecs
c'est très dur de gagner une partie donc
waseige en retrait contre nadal à roland
garros et avant du premier set bon déjà
c'est gagner le premier set tu sais que
ça va être chaud et n était même pas
favoris mais bon qui étudient battrons
pour gagner le match bien qu'on s'est
pas réuni 1,7 puis ont gagné un deuxième
pour peta a dit le troisième
mais là donc du couvent a été menée 1
set 0 bon c'est pas fini je n'étais pas
trop bien quoi
et même pas bien du tout
cinq parties c'est la position qu'on
voyait un el-assad vrai tout est changé
ouais non là ça tout échange
beaucoup d'autres
cinq casques épreuve trois échecs en
fête et sûrs cavaliers décade pour
essayer un peu quelque chose avec la f3
quand même puis dame française 5
bref un ça passe
à l'écran extra joly
gonfard watch
mes choix sont ceux des clous juste ou
non là il se passera plus rien
après quand ils peuvent pas fermer avant
leur 40e coup ouais bon peut-être il va
faire ça
je veux dire c'est que normalement il
aurait
normalement il aurait proposé accepté
nul mais ils vont trouver une quinzaine
de coups en corse a pu dire un peu de
temps
mais en retour sur un rush de tournage
de roger pause en mai prochain ça tombe
bien sûr de bien acheter trois fois
mais bon à vrai dire c'est vraiment le
résultat qu'on attendait hier soir après
la partie c'est le résultat qu'on
s'attende et voir ce matin bon je dirais
deux choix c'est soi n'est pour rien au
lean soit il faisait ça nul sans trop
chercher et je regroupe quoi en gros
pour souffler demain faut qu'ils
tiennent avec les noirs
enfin et s'y tient avec les normes après
la 3 chance avec les blancs on va faire
autre chose que ça en tout cas
marveaux qui réfléchissent aussi
longtemps pour afficher ou pour visser
la nulle alors que c'est encore lors
d'une pub ce sera probablement la
dernière de la journée fab ouais bonne
chance
bah tout
on vient dans cinq petites minutes
les amis en objet d'un tout petit peu et
porter la pause ce que ça boudreau comme
prévu
comme prévu mais voilà on est revenu on
a coupé la pause juste à temps
magnifique partie aujourd'hui encore ah
oui non mais aujourd'hui pas très bonne
partie en scène
peut-être
on va regarder les quatre vingts
peut-être c'est la plus grande partie
qu'on ait jamais vu on verra un et score
mais en tout cas très propre de la party
carl scène
n'est pas au bar rien obtenu après
c'était prévisible qui une partie comme
ça un peu de pauses
pas juste occire c'était très long les
joueurs étaient fatigués donc voilà ils
vont revenir demain et puis voir la
suite en tout cas carlson se rapproche
du sacre
ça va à son rythme ça suit sa filière et
ça se passe très bien pour le jour
norvégien
se parle un petit peu les deux joueurs
n'ont clairement leur parti qu'on
attendait aujourd'hui une époque qui
aura tout perdu ou un chat perdu et la
partie et les blonds ou aujourd'hui cij
a pris très cher en fait ça de très
moyen ça fait vraiment très mal
non mais des fois c'est pas plus mal de
faire une nulle pour se remettre plutôt
que d'aller
reperdre avec la soul en coton fille
voilà en tout cas carlson et bien il est
serein et confortable dans ce match et
ça ça continue pour lui a juste bien se
passer
bon on va vous faire un petit un petit
résumé ouais un petit résumé mais qui va
partir sur bitstream puis on se retrouve
demain
de nouvelles aventures et une partie à
mon avis qui va jouer et peut-être
finalement c'est comme je le disais
c'est peut-être la meilleure chance pour
les peaux essayer de contrer ou noir
voilà savoir quand ma news contre joué
mais là il va prendre encore moins de
risques iard quoi
j'essaie de faire jouer sans puis si un
truc parce qu milliards à un moment il
pourrait vous faire cailler détroit
juste échange tout
[Musique]
on m'a merci à tous d'avoir suivi et on
vous dit à demain